you are watching Kohl's piston TV
looking at the big picture of technology
smartphones are Sony and have grown so
fast that much of the general public
hasn't really taken note of what's going
on around them these are the top five
mind-blowing facts about your smartphone
let's dive in number five NASA used them
as cheap satellites the smartphone
industry has pushed the boundaries of
low-cost high performance solutions so
far that the average smartphone has more
computing power and memory than the
average satellite in addition to this
smart phones already have a GPS multiple
accelerometers motion sensors radio
receivers and more for well under $1000
NASA noticed this unique anomaly in
modern technology and in 2009 they
created project phone set this project
is an ongoing experiment that uses
smartphones as a satellites onboard
computer there have been multiple
versions launched as newer phones are
released the orbital lifespan is said to
be one year it's pretty cool number four
smartphones are the fastest growing
industry in history and today the
industry is worth over 300 billion
dollars to really understand just how
big that is we have to compare it to the
next closest thing humanity has seen the
PC market compared to the PC market the
smartphone industry has been growing at
a rate of four times the maximum rate of
PC growth in January 2014 for the first
time in history mobile phone internet
usage overtook PC Internet usage and
that's not all in the period between
1975 and June 2008 1 billion pcs were
sold this includes desktops laptops
servers and everything combined in
comparison smartphone sales topped 1
billion in just 2013 alone the sales
have been so rapid that even on YouTube
some smartphone reviewers have been made
celebrities in their own right
smartphones are only getting more
popular with low-cost high performance
options such as the Nexus 5 and Sony
Xperia Z compact and in addition to this
so-called developing nations are
absolutely loving smart phones India has
the fastest-growing smartphone market in
the world it's all pretty interesting
stuff and has really only just been
taken off in the last year or so
number three smartphones are actually
slowly changing the world in 2014 mobile
traffic is almost 15 percent of the
continent of Africa's data use in Egypt
seventy percent of people say they don't
even touch desktop or laptops to access
the web they only use mobile in May 2012
a study from the University of Colorado
found that the average person belonging
to Generation Y has their phones with
them 91 percent of the day and they're
very likely to use their phones to meet
up with each other
settle arguments or solve unexpected
problems Generation Y and Zed basically
my generation has grown up with the
internet and the smart phone was
basically the next logical step some say
that it's making this generation less
social but that's really up to the
individual
in addition to this smartphones have
made colossal dents in the sales of
point-and-shoot cameras camcorders
newspapers print media in general
netbooks
portable gaming systems mp3 players and
basically most things you can think of
now of course the smartphone wouldn't
have been able to do this by itself is
the smartphone plus the collective
knowledge of everyone through the
internet that has caused this shift to
really see how integral the Internet has
become in modern society today here's an
interesting bit of insight the following
clip is from a 2013 BBC documentary that
takes a rare look into the university
life of North Koreans I found the
following extract to be very interesting
American electorate Aaron think invites
me to talk to her students he's had one
day at the end of 30 days no Michael
Jackson Michael James
my goodness makes this on Easter right
now he's not the president hey he's my
intern Michael Jackson he was a very
famous singer yeah normally if you
didn't know who someone was he could
just google it or search it up without
the internet this is not an option
number two your smartphone is more
powerful than you think this one will
blow your mind for this fact we have to
go back on a journey through time and
space like we often do on this channel
so the year is 1946 and on this year the
first-ever general-purpose
fully electronic computer was created
its name was in yet the ENIAC computer
took up an entire room and required
colossal amounts of energy just to
complete 385 calculations per second
fast forward to last year so 2013 and
the Snapdragon 800 chip that is not
uncommon in most smartphones can do 28
billion calculations per second in other
words it would take 72 million ENIAC
computers just to make up the power of
one smartphone chip let's push this fact
a little bit further that's over two
billion tons of ENIAC computer
components and you don't even want to
guess how much space this will take up
all practicality aside if you could
place all of these ENIAC computers
back-to-back and as close as you could
possibly get them all the components
together would take up a landmass of how
big maybe you'd guess a football stadium
or maybe a small city not even close to
have the equivalent power of one
smartphone chip it would take 11.8
million square kilometers of ENIAC
computer components that's 20% larger
than the entire area of the United
States of America and all of that now
can fit on your finger now it's
definitely something to think about
number one by definition your smartphone
is a PC PC is the acronym for personal
computer and the smartphone has come a
long way even since 2010 here let me
show you this is a stock smartphone
running android you can plug it into a
monitor with the keyboard and mouse and
you can actually do some work with it
hypothetically if your desktop computer
was unaccessible for one reason or
another maybe it was broken or in repair
you could use your phone to get some
actual productivity tasks done
comfortably and that's not all
nowadays if you have an Android phone
you can stick USB sticks in there and
even some hardware things such as fans
work and with that that rounds out the
top fly of mind-blowing facts about your
smartphone so I understand that this was
a whole lot of mind blow to take in just
for one video so let's do a bit of a
recap NASA has used smartphones as
low-cost satellites the smartphone
industry is the fastest growing industry
in history smartphones are changing
society today's smartphones are over 70
million times faster than the first
electronic computer not to mention that
it would take an area 20% larger than
the entire USA to have that equivalent
power and lastly today's smartphone can
be used as a PC
hey guys to go get here the creator
editor and scriptwriter and all that of
that video and of course this channel
and I just want to thank you for
watching the whole way through you know
I've been wondering span is decreasing
that's quite sad but thanks for watching
and you know factors often stranger than
fiction as they say so you may
found one or two facts in there that you
found interesting and if you did well
feel free to pass along to one of your
friends and blow their minds too because
really the world we live in nowadays is
actually changing quite rapidly and no
one's really documenting what's
happening at the moment so you know I
thought it might be a little bit of a
pioneer or something like that and try
and do this kind of new cutting-edge
kind of documentary kind of thing so
anyway I yeah that's enough of my
rambling thanks for watching and until
next time I shall see you soon so as
usual don't forget to rate comment and
subscribe and enjoy the rest of your day
cheers guys video cassette in camera
system everyone's been talking about
this system sold nationally for one
thousand two hundred forty nine dollars
but we're liquidating our entire
inventory immediately so we've slashed
our price to just $6.99
yep six hundred ninety nine dollars was
the discounted price
so really anytime you wanted to shoot a
video you'd have to run around with a
heavy VCR over your shoulder it's much
simpler today in 1983 Sony finally
solved this by releasing the BMC 100 P
system this was the first ever truly
portable camcorder